[Música]
los líderes mundiales se enfrentan a una
ola masiva y mundial de presión social
miles de personas han salido a las
calles de varias ciudades a demostrar su
enojo por la falta de acciones concretas
y significativas para limitar el
calentamiento global en la cob 26 les
exigen resultados claros en francia el
grupo ambientalista extinción rebelión
organizó una protesta con disfraces de
terror y así mostrar los horrores que
conlleva la falta de acción contra el
cambio climático odioso turizo que nos
encontramos cada año en las conferencias
mundiales sobre el clima que se repiten
y cada vez nos encontramos al final de
la conferencia decepcionados frustrados
enfadados porque el gobierno no parece
proponer planes de acción que estén a la
altura de sus retos sexual autor si
somos hoy en bruselas varios centenares
de manifestantes marcharon hacia el
parlamento europeo
los cientos de activistas también
alzaron su voz en alemania para que se
limite el uso del carbón y combustibles
fósiles mientras que los dirigentes y
activistas ambientales ya han escuchado
el llamado de un pueblo enojado y
pericles
young people of fair world ya ha quedado
muy claro que los jóvenes están
preocupados por el futuro y están
enfadados y creo que tienen todo el
derecho a estarlo porque los líderes
mundiales a lo largo del tiempo no han
cumplido el time have el chuleta creo
que es necesario enfadar a algunas
personas por supuesto mientras nadie
salga herido como por ejemplo el
movimiento de la huelga escolar por el
clima nunca habría llegado a ser tan
grande si no hubiera habido fricciones
los líderes mundiales tendrán dos días
de discursos en la cob 26 en donde se
esperan nuevos compromisos sobre la
reducción de emisiones la eliminación
progresiva de los combustibles fósiles y
la financiación para lograr economías
más verdes